and here it is the Independent Spirit
Award itself the Independent Spirit
Award statue designed by Carol boss'll
'men symbolizes the Independent Spirit
this bronze sculpture and I'm quoting
now features an abstract bird
symbolizing the independent filmmaker
taking flight from atop a classical
column representing the classical
Hollywood studio system clutched in the
talons of the bird of independence are
entwined shoestrings in the shape of
pieces of film an allegory yes an
allegory about the budgets within which
independent filmmakers must work or you
might think of it as representing one of
the escaped Disney studio experimental
cost-cutting message service homing
Falcons flying backwards for secrecy and
carrying the latest microfilm leveraged
buyout offer from a Japanese media
consortium to the cleverly disguised
false greco-roman maildrop
outside of the CIA garage now let's give
these damn things away to present the
first award Bruce Davison who won one of
these things last year for longtime
companion and we'd like to present this
to someone who for seven years has been
our independent award could I hear how
much we love buck Henry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no standing up with the stomach full of
paella thank you very much I'd say I
don't know what to say but you'd know it
was a lie I'll take this home and do
something with it that not one of you
can imagine to present the first real
award Bruce Davison who was one of one
one of these things last year for a long
time companion and Lily Taylor who may
or may not win one of these this year
for bright angel which if she does we'll
fill that agonizing gap in her life as
it has mine Bruce Davison and Lily
Taylor
[Music]
I can't wait to hear your jokes about it
next year buck I guess that kid we're
giving the cinematography Awards and I'm
supposed to start out with a little
known fact the early cameraman got their
jobs by being able to crank consistently
at 16 frames per second okay to get the
proper lighting the set was simply
turned or rotated around to follow the
Sun okay yes the nominees for Best
Cinematography are Roger Deakins for
homicide
Eric Alan Edwards and John Campbell for
my own private Idaho
Johnny Jensen for ramblin rose
Walt Lloyd for Kafka and Tom Richmond
for pastime
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I once seen
thank you very much I'd like to thank of
course horror song Steven Soderbergh
Kodak and Panavision who were great with
their technical expertise and health but
especially to some people that I think
Oh forgotten when we come here and
celebrate every year and that is the
crew that hauls cable and lace track and
hangs lights after 14 hours rain and
snow and sleet
I really appreciate the crews that have
hung with me through all of these
independent films they don't hang up
when I call them and say this is a great
script
do you mind working for a half year rate
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks Bruce thanks Lily congratulations
Walt it is a beautiful film and I know
it will look even better when it's
colorized
here's a brand new award category best
film music and here to hum the list of
nominees are the bad boy from Thelma &
Louise and the good girl from Godfather
3 not to be confused with three
Godfather's starring Pedro armendariz
1949 er there abouts Brad Pitt and Sofia
Coppola
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
being a new category all right
the nominees for best film music are
hanging with the homeboys David Sackler
and Joel so kiss me a killer
Marcus Loya and Nigel Holden matter of
degrees Randall posture and Jim Dunbar
[Applause]
and straight out of Brooklyn Harold
wheeler
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks a lot for this word bill Stafford
who played most of the pedal steel and
improvised along with home on the range
and america the beautiful' the sort of
on the cheap together scored it and so
i'm here to clip the award but it was a
collaboration of all the musicians that
came into the studio at one time or
another and played the saw or the bongos
or whatever and i thank you for this
award and i think new line and vine line
for helping with the picture and laurie
Parker for producing thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you congratulations guys I sort of
knew you'd win something cuz I I've
always had the feeling that America had
been holding its breath waiting for a
film about two gay guys who speak in
iambic pentameter and finally you've
done it well to present the best
director award what can I say about this
pair actor writer director and sex
symbol Robert Townsend and international
film star producer and a credit to her
race Jacqueline Bisset
[Music]
now they gave us Best Screenplay you
said best director thanks buck so it's
best screenplay unlike today words
actually stood by themselves in the
early films words were fed to actors by
means of a card I was just wondering
what we're talking about whether anyway
apparently actors back then they focused
more on their on their actions that on
their words and that's why it just just
seems so overly emotional
and now the nominations for Best
Screenplay right Floyd buyers and free
chav Capra mine walk
[Applause]
Michael token the rapture Joseph B
Vasquez hanging with the homeboys and
the winner is Gus Van Sant my own
private
[Applause]
it's Gus here he's come he's got a long
walk more applause Gus Gus
[Music]
um thanks got my table so far away I'm
sorry
they say I have to thank William
Shakespeare for the whole section in the
middle of the film that is straight out
of his works and let's see who else can
I think maybe my primary cast to have
the likely names of River
Keanu FLE Fudo and bill
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all of you congratulations
again Gus stay close to give the Award
for Best Supporting Actor am i right
two actors ladies and gentlemen two
actors with six names Lou Diamond
Phillips and Laura San Jacomo I think he
missed the obvious one which would have
been standing deliver Sex Lies and
videotape it works I don't know anyway
we're supposed to go straight to the
nominees for Best Supporting Actor and
they are John Malkovich Queens logic
[Applause]
Glenn Plummer pastime
[Applause]
and the person in the envelope is there
in city of Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they say they say a great actor can
actually transform himself he's good
he's not this good
David is I'm John Schloss I'm the
executive producer of City of Hope and
David's on his way down to Louisiana to
shoot John's current film which
hopefully will be as good and much more
popular and I'm sure he would thank John
Sayles and Maggie Renzi and Sarah green
and everyone at Columbia TriStar
and I will get this to him thank you the
next one is force Best Supporting
Actress and here to present it our two
actors who will make any sacrifice in
pursuit of their craft in rush Jennifer
Jason Leigh let her hair get all nasty
and dirty and shot herself full of all
manner of awful drugs and in white
palace James Spader had to have oral sex
with Susan Sarandon what more can I say
Jennifer Jason Leigh and James Spader
[Applause]
[Music]
the nominees for Best Supporting Actress
are Diane Ladd for ramblin rose
Sheila McCarthy Bright Angel Deirdre
O'Connell for pastime Emma Thompson
impromptu Mary Ward and the winner is
Diane Ladd ramblin rose
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's called a human race and when you
get an opportunity run honey don't walk
I don't have to do it in 30 seconds my
god I can talk okay I would like to
thank some people I would like to thank
first of all in the beginning was the
word mister called a willingham for one
of the best scripts I was ever
privileged to read mr. Edgar sherek for
finding that script and bringing it home
miss Martha Coolidge a great director
for finding Edgar sherek in that script
she gave it to a fellow actress whom
I'll talk about in second and that
actress suggested I read it but I didn't
I was doing a film called plain clothes
with Martha and she said to me at dinner
one day my god you really are my mother
I said I beg your pardon
she said no in my script read it I did I
fell in love with it
we tried to get it made year after year
five years ago I got involved I got
permission from Edgar sherek and Martha
to try and do it myself - I spend $3,500
of my own money with scripts under my
arm knocking on doors being told it was
too good we should do it for television
then Renny Harlin asked Laura if he
could take a look at the script he said
what's that he read it he fell in love
with it he said I want to direct this
she said you can we are committed to
moth the Coolidge and he did an
incredible thing and this takes
integrity he said by God if I can't
direct this I'm gonna help get it
produced it's got to be made and he took
it to Mario Kassar who made our film and
I want to thank all of them I want to
thank also Bob Shaye and newline and
Mitch Goldman
I want to thank Johnny Jensen and great
cinema photographer Elmer Bernstein for
his music Jane Robinson for her costumes
I want to thank a great cast
I want to thank Lukas Haas Lee standing
right over there Lucas stand up over
there and take a bow you Brea talent you
and I'd like to thank Robert eval Lisa
Jacobs Evan Lockwood my six year old
down in Carolina whom we called Evan
from heaven and now I'd like to thank a
special lady who I'm glad she didn't
listen to a mother when I told her not
to be an actress a lady that I not only
loved with all of my heart someone that
I've been asked quite often by
interviewers do you and your daughter
compete my answer is no we do not
compete let us stop that all of us
competing like dogs after a bone and
this planet of ours which has so many
problems today where there's a famine of
truth and I want to thank Oliver Stone
for doing JFK there's a famine of
communication a famine of compassion and
a famine of love and where all this is I
say to every single parent for God's
sakes take your children let them stand
on your shoulders and truly maybe they
will be able to see further than we did
and this little planet won't be in such
a mess and I want to thank my daughter a
great actress in her own right the star
of our film ramblin rose thank all of
you
[Applause]
[Music]
God scuse me may I please thank Joan
hilar my lovely agent at William Morris
and my great friend and managers
Stephanie her Coast's if it wasn't for
your support
hell I've probably gone back to
Mississippi and be picking cotton
Stephanie thank you for being you
[Applause]
I'd like to thank my agent at William
Morris for sitting through this Thank
You Diane who would imagine that she's
Alan Ladd's daughter well perhaps I'm
wrong best first feature is the next
category and here to make someone
hysterically happy with it our to swell
people Liam Neeson who as the Nazi
officer in shining through displayed the
most intriguing accent since Sean
Connery played an Arab and Teresa
Russell who demonstrated such
verisimilitude in hooker that she proved
to me at least that she always has a
back up profession Liam Neeson and
Teresa Russell
[Applause]
[Music]
okay fuck right
buck Henry that's your name is your
agent okay so the nominees for the best
the best first best first feature our
chameleon straight dong Laden producer
poison Christine Vishal the rapture Nick
Wechsler Nancy Tenenbaum current
[Applause]
straight out of Brooklyn
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Brooklyn well um thank my mom my sister
for giving me the credit cards - -
straight out of Brooklyn my grandmother
for putting holes in her apartment door
and things like that Sam you're going
company American Playhouse IRA durch
Mentalist man huh and I always like to
talk about when I go around schools and
talk to young people because I made the
movie I'm a big man I'm 20 now I made it
at the age of 17 and I I talk about how
I made it and why I made it growing up
in Red Hook housing projects in Brooklyn
not seeing the Brady Bunch family seeing
all of my city
the only six friends that I have died on
one street corner the only thing that
could keep me alive was reading film
books I never went to college I taught
myself how to become a filmmaker just to
keep myself alive because I wanted to
stay alive at before at the age of 15 so
I taught myself how to become a
filmmaker by using my eyes and my brains
and by reading and determination and
persistence and I talked to talk about
that a lot to my peers we'll get you up
here thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all good work the first time I can
remember that a borough has been thanked
here to dispose of the Award for Best
Director is that beloved vaudeville team
Johnny Scissorhands depth and Lily's
scalpel Tong Tomlin
[Music]
nominees for Best Director are Martha
Coolidge for ramblin rose Todd Haynes
for poison richard linklater for slacker
Gus Van Sant for my own private Idaho
and Joseph B Vasquez for hanging with
the homeboys the winner is somewhere
Martha Coolidge ramen roll
[Applause]
[Music]
well I want to thank Diane for making my
speech shorter I want to thank everyone
here this film was a dream excuse me for
a very long time and it took me five
years to get it made and it took Edgar
sharukh 17 and I want to thank Edgar and
I want to thank Calder for his beautiful
script and Edgar for hanging in there
and Laura for falling in love with it
when I gave it to her five years ago or
six years ago now and forgiving it to
Rennie and Diane for her beautiful
performance and Laura for hers and
Rennie of course for fighting to get
made and Mario for making it and Bobbie
Duval and Lucas house for their
beautiful performances the whole rest of
the cast and the crew especially
especially Johnny for hanging in to
having done four pictures with me and
doing a beautiful job on ramblin rose
which was his first feature as a DP and
all the rest of my incredible crew and
of course my husband for hanging in
there with me as we all know his
independent filmmakers there are a lot
of ups and downs and a lot of downs and
the ups are great and this is one and I
just want to say that I was told when I
applied to graduate film school that I
couldn't be a director because I was a
woman they accepted me anyway which was
sort of a mystery to me but I hung in
there and there were many many times
when I didn't know how I could go on but
I want to thank an actor who told me
when I first came to Hollywood
he said talent counts but above all what
really counts is perseverance and I want
to tell you it really is true and I'm
here to say you can do it all of you can
do it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good work Martha so much for sexism in
this group as I was saying to Barbour
the other day here to unload the Award
for Best Actor our two fine actors in
their own right is wonderful cliche what
first of all what can I say about Danny
Aiello that he hasn't already said about
himself an accomplished method actor
Danny I've been told prepared for his
role as Jack Ruby by trying to kill Gary
Oldman and as for Mimi Rogers in the
rapture for which she has been nominated
she gives up all kinds of depraved sex
to search for God sort of like st.
Augustine only younger and a lot more
zaftig Danny Aiello Mimi Rogers
[Applause]
[Music]
it's nice being here it's nice being
anywhere I want to think the
independence I want to thank the
independence of a given Ruby an
opportunity of playing I doubt very much
if that movie would have been made had
it not been for propaganda films I want
to thank him in the silent era
Valentino's acting was with an eye a
look or a stare Fairbanks was an
adventurous act of doing his own stunts
so how do we define Best Actor these
days but I would probably define best
acting as believability when the
character seems genuine
oh yes and the nominees for Best Actor
are dougie Doug hanging with the
homeboys Rob adieu Val for ramblin rose
gary oldman Rosencrantz and Guildenstern
are dead that's the guy I shot isn't it
a JFK River Phoenix for my own private
idle and William R Us for pastime and
the winner sorry honey and the winner is
River Phoenix my own private Idaho
[Music]
thank you to Gus Van Sant for an amazing
script and opportunity in a role Mike is
an amazing part to play I'm sure you'd
like to thank Matt Ebert and Scott
Greene in Portland and I know just
personally I think that his in glory
Parker hey Laurie hi we produced the
whole thing in Eric and John who the DPS
and civet Agra fur I know he did an
amazing performance an amazing part an
amazing film and
[Applause]
[Music]
so what follows Best Actor why Best
Actress of course and to tell us who
that will be our Jobeth Williams who to
me is always the girl wife mistress next
door and Joe Mantegna without whom David
Mamet would be considered just another
Pulitzer Prize winning postmodern
Mannerist Joe and Joe Beth
[Music]
hi Joe hi Jill Beth these are all
wonderful actresses I think we'll just
go right to the nominees Judy Davis for
impromptu Patsy Kensit for 21 Mimi
Rogers for the rapture
Lily Taylor for Bright Angel Lily Tomlin
for the search for signs of intelligent
life in the universe and the winner is
Judy Davis in prompter
[Music]
is not here she is actually in Australia
shooting a film but I know she would
have asked somebody if she known she was
going to win to thank all of you very
much well I'm gonna take it in her stead
and give it to one of the other people
who is here who else to present the best
foreign film award but to genuine
certified foreigners julian sand has
starred in many films in many countries
and because he is english speaks a
language very much like our own except
for her role as Marina Oswald in JFK
that spelled JFK most of Beata pozniak's
work has been in her native Poland where
she is performed in many plays and films
the titles of which I can't tell you
because the words of no vowels in them
Julian Sands piata posniak
[Applause]
[Music]
do you worry about it though bottom
usually is them today so the nominees
that was a Polish joke okay jin da-rae
Dava zhenya Prussia putzi so the
nominees for the best foreign film an
angel at my table director Jane Campion
the double life of Veronique directed by
Christophe Kozlov steep life is sweet
directed by Mike Lee taxi blues directed
by pavel
longuine angel at my table
[Applause]
[Music]
Jane Campion is also in Australia
Oh new zealand sorry
hi but i know if she were he or she
would ease their there say thank you or
something new zealand like it's hard to
eat spaghetti and finally the award for
best feature and here to tell us what
film gets that and who's going to argue
with them Rebecca De Mornay the girl who
rocks your cradle and Anthony Hopkins
the guy who eats your face
[Music]
yeah
the nominees for best feature film are
City of Hope producer Sarah green and
Maggie Renzi hanging in with the
homeboys producer Richard Vick homicide
this is Michael Houseman and Edward
Edward are Pressman my own Private Idaho
producer Boney Baca ramblin rose
producer Renny Harlin and the winner is
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Renny is climbing the peaks of some help
with sly shooting a movie that's not
well it is an independent film in a way
and but he splashed me this this morning
so I'll I'll read it to you
the last time I won an award was ten
years ago in Finland it was for a coffee
commercial needless to say this award
this award means the world to me I want
to thank Laura Dern for giving me the
screenplay Mario Kassar for giving me
the money
Martha Coolidge for giving me the movie
and my mother for giving birth to me
naturally naturally we couldn't have
done it without the greatest cast and
crew thank you Renny Harlin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You mr. Mornay Thank You mr.
Hopkins thank you miss Coolidge those
are the awards we have a biggie left
couple of Biggie's in fact if there is a
towering giant in the independent film
racket and there is his name is Roger
Corman he's he's produced more than 175
films and directed 50 others he's
written them and he's even distributed
them and now in his twilight years the
greedy son of a bitch is acting in them
he started more people in the business
than all the film schools put together
Coppola Scorsese Bogdanovich Ron Howard
Jonathan Demi Joe Danity Nicholson De
Niro the list goes on ad infinitum he's
one of the few producers who has
consistently placed women in positions
of authority and moviemaking he's made
films that cost less than his car
finally I think there's a lesson to be
learned although I'm not quite sure what
it is from the fact that the guy who did
postgraduate work in modern English
literature at Oxford College is the same
guy who made swamp women monsters from
the ocean floor piranha eat my dust and
she guards of Shark Reef Roger Corman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'd like to take you back for a moment
to the early 1960s when I was following
the Formula One Grand Prix racing
circuit around Europe making a film
called the young racers on that film I
had the greatest staff I ever had and I
think one of the greatest staffs anybody
ever had my number three assistant was
Bob town number two assistant was
Menachem Golan and number one was
Francis Coppola they were all young
ambitious hard-working guys or at least
two of them were Bob Towne was a little
laid-back even bad but Francis and
Menachem worked I cannot tell you how
hard they worked and if anybody wants to
talk about brakes or anything else I'll
digress from what I was about to say and
say the combination of ability and hard
work in my opinion really does it every
time they worked so hard that as we
approach the end of the picture I had an
idea which I'd had before and have had
since which was we had all our equipment
there in a microbus built in that
Francis had done part of the
construction on and we had the crew and
the cast and I thought why not make a
second picture we've got half of it
amortized already so I talked to Francis
about writing and directing a picture I
had to go back to do another film in the
United States and I talked to Menachem
about writing on directing another
picture and they each came to me with
ideas as to the picture they would make
I chose Francis Menachem will tell me to
this day that I made a major mistake at
that time but I don't think I did
Francis made a picture called dementia
13 a startlingly well-made and
frightening little picture in which he
demonstrated in his first feature film
the great ability he had both as a
creator and is the fact that he brought
the film in exactly on budget and on
schedule Francis on March 1st I came to
the Philippines with Francis and our
three children Gio 12 Roman 10 and
Sophia for Francis has asked me to make
a documentary film for the United
Artists publicity department I don't
know if he wants to avoid the addition
of the professional team and I'm already
overloaded production or if he is just
trying to keep me busy and I'm feeling
like a idiot
having set in motion stuff that doesn't
make any sense that doesn't match and
yet I'm doing it and the reason I'm
doing it is that a desperation because I
have no rational way to do it what I
have to admit is that I don't know what
I'm doing you can't put the discrepancy
between what you feel about it
because they see the magic of what has
happened before I'm saying hey it's not
gonna happen
I don't have any performances the script
doesn't make sense I have no anything
I'm like God I'm like a voice crying out
saying please it's not working
somebody get me off this and nobody
listens to me everyone says yes when
Francis works best in a crisis I'm
saying this is one crisis I'm not gonna
pull myself out of I'm making a bad
movie so why should I go ahead I'd
rather I'm gonna be bankrupt anyway why
can't I just have the courage to say
it's no good me the grateful to that
magical eight millimeter video recorders
and stuff around some just people who
normally wouldn't make movies are gonna
be making them you know suddenly one day
some little fat girl in Ohio is gonna be
the new Mozart you know and make a
beautiful film with her little father's
camera a quarter and for once the so
called professionalism about movies will
be destroyed forever
you know and it'll really become an art
form
I was invited to make a keynote speech I
I had it worked out this morning it was
it was a lot of thoughts a lot of
feelings I was afraid because I tried to
I I came down from San Francisco this
morning and I tried to put some ideas I
was afraid that it would be very chaotic
but so much time has gone by and I'm
we're all so tired of me actually it may
actually work you know I want to just
make one comment about that film clip I
didn't know I was gonna get it but you
know I would go home and and and
complain to my wife I was I would go
home and say how much trouble I was
having hoping I would get a lot of
sympathy and comfort I realized that she
was gonna record it all and I was gonna
so it's been so long please those of you
want to stand up and get some coffee
I'll I'll I'm gonna really just tell you
some of my feelings some of my opinions
today and for what they're worth so much
of my life and career have been really
spent and the idea of being involved
with an independent group of creative
people I was the typical drama student
of the of the 50s you know we were we
were putting on productions in college
and we we felt tried to be independent
from the faculty who had all the control
and at that time we started a drama club
and tried to get the means of production
and it seems I was 17 then it seems that
we've been doing something like that
ever since the so called means of
production at first I thought that being
that I was had come from writing and and
technology I was kind of a boy scientist
and was first attracted to a theater
because of the lighting equipment and
the lighting boards and and so to me the
means of production meant that we we had
to write scripts and we had to own
cameras so a bunch of us around 1960 I
guess eight drove up to San Francisco
with some u-haul trucks and proceeded to
try to get the means of production which
meant in fact that we bought cameras and
we got editing machines and we tried to
write scripts and that was we formed
American zoetrope
those of you who don't know this the
word zoetrope comes from the early
Victorian toy which was the drum that
spins around and one of the precursors
of cinema's OE of course means life and
trope means turn and we thought of
ourselves as a kind of life turn or life
life life revolution even that we were
going to participate in a in a beginning
of really what all of you here are
participating in independent means to
make films and you know what happened is
we we had the equipment and we were
writing scripts many of the people there
you you would know but though at that
first phase of zoetrope American
zoetrope we we learned no that wasn't
the answer to the means of production
that it wasn't owning the qyp equipment
it was like having the money so that we
could own the film that we could own the
negative and so we spent another group
of years trying to put together that and
we did we did have some success and and
we did have enough money to to actually
pay for the film and thereby own the
negative and when that was done it sort
of didn't work or there was a series of
misadventures as usual and I said no no
that's not the answer at the owning to
the means of production is it's not it's
not it wasn't the equipment and it's not
it's not having the money to be able to
own the film it's the distribution so we
tried in the in the late 70s to to be
able to make our films and control the
distributions that was the period of
right around Apocalypse Now which we had
tried to do in a way and and to this day
American zoetrope does own Apocalypse
Now and about eight films that we made
at that time but still there were more
misadventures and and I said no it's not
the distribution actually it it really
came down to there was all of the above
that you had to have all of the above
which but sort of comes down to what
they referred to as as the power or the
cloud I remember being very impressed I
was reading a book about Orson Welles
and we were all of course very inspired
by his career but the book had said that
that Orson had neglected his base of
power that he had
he had become so far removed from any
base of power that he could that he
could have behind him that that it was
that base of power was essential and
there we were up in San Francisco sort
of away from everyone
we had no partners we really had no base
of power and I was very fearful as beat
down all filmmakers the great fear is
that you're not going to ever be able to
make a film again you're not gonna ever
be able to put the wherewithal together
to make a film and I guess then I said
well maybe an important thing it's not
the equipment and it's not just the
money it's maybe the partners and the
affiliations because if you have
partners I always thought that when I
had that beautiful coming to the studio
sort of makes me a little sad because it
was a lot like the studio we had and I'd
often thought that well I I've heard of
companies getting in trouble and being
overextended but someone always helps
them through I mean Chrysler was in
trouble and Columbia Pictures I remember
years ago there was always some some
person that helps you through but when
zoetrope was in trouble we had no
partners we had no affiliations and so
we just sort of you know sunk into the
mire and the studio was sold off at just
a few dollars and if you wanted to buy
it today it would cost ten times the
amount so I guess in in in now slightly
more advanced here and in the same quest
to have the means of production I
thought well it will be if it will be
partners it will zoetrope wouldn't want
to be the kind of company just does
everything on its own and be independent
be up in San Francisco that we we want
to reach reach out to other similar
companies and make every project we do
sort of a partnership and that way
number one you don't if you're getting a
little trouble your partner will help
get you out you know and well it's about
the 25th year of zoetrope we're still in
business and now we do have many
partners and were involved in many
projects so maybe in a way that was took
me a while to arrive at that those
affiliations with other filmmakers
directors even companies and so that's
more the the approach that that we've
taken now and
it makes me think you know I'm also in
the wine business and there's something
about the wine business many things
about the wine business is very very
similar to the film business the
technical process is very much the same
I won't dwell on that but someday if
anyone asked me about the parallels
between winemaking and filmmaking
they're really very very striking
especially that in Napa where we do so
much of our work the wine company and
the film company in fact are in the same
building and you see this parallel
process going on you know you gather the
grapes which is you know go out and get
the footage and some day it's really
good and sometimes not so good but you
pump it around and filter it and work it
there the analogies are are very
interesting but the point I wanted to
maybe try to make about this notion of
affiliations and partners is like the
wine business my experience in the film
business has been that the affiliation
of the people has is always so warm in
in Napa Valley when you live there and
you know many of the people who are
making wine no one ever will say
anything bad about another person's wine
it's almost as though that they love
what they're making so much that this is
this is very very true that immediately
when you try to go into wine people come
and and kind of offer their help I
remember Robert Mondavi who is a
wonderful man and a kind of you know
father figure to much of the wine
industry really comes and talks to you
and helps you and you never hear someone
saying something bad about someone's
wine almost as though it's it's there
it's it's a it's a business that people
are in out there really because they
love wine and they love the romance of
wine and my experience as a in that film
really has been very similar as I I
don't honestly ever recall talking with
a filmmaker and hearing them bum
wrapping another filmmaker it's
something that I love about the
profession is that you know is that we
have so many wonderful directors in this
country American directors and directors
from other countries and I really remark
how it's so similar to the wine
profession in that regard that that you
don't have that thing that you have in
other professions maybe because in other
professions the love of the actual work
itself is not as dramatic as it is for
people who love and appreciate them you
see a good film you feel wonderful you
feel inspired to go make to make a film
yourself and it's sort of the way it is
in in the wine industry and I was so
encouraged and and really inspired by
some of the people who were the people
of my generations that we looked up to
that's something very very precious to
cultivate I think this this idea that I
would go on that a little later I want
to talk about sports and film as I as I
as I get onto that what what I want to
say about sports and film is that it
seems to me that in recent years you
read about films you read a lot of
numbers you read about how much the
budgets were or you read about every
Monday what the grosses are and my
instinct is that that's something that's
a kind of throwback or relation to more
of a mentality of sports where in the
paper you read who won and who lost and
what was the score but in sports maybe
there do have to be losers and winners
but in film which is to say in our art I
don't think that there can only be there
can be just winners it's different that
the numbers are not really important to
happen the reason that the numbers are
stressed in the papers is to give people
who write about it perhaps a handle to
be able to say oh we know who's doing
well and who's not doing well in a field
that really defies that type of judgment
another another thought I've thought
about a lot is was this question of
variety that my impression always was
that there were many kinds of films that
you can make that that there there are
unlimited types of films yet in our
actual practice it seems now that there
are three or four types of viable films
you can make rather than 40 or a 30 or
40 in the past even there was a time
when there might be many many different
types of films available you know
histories and musicals and and social
realism kind of variety of filmmaking
but now it seems that there's only sort
of like what television was like years
ago when you would say well I have an
idea and make someone on that that type
of idea wouldn't work for television and
you say I have another idea no it's only
that kind of idea you wonder well how
did the choice of what types of shows
could go and they'll kind of get so
small and now I I look around in the
film business for the last well 15 years
maybe the same amount of time that many
of those television executives were
running the network's now became the
point of running the studios but it
seems that there aren't lots of kinds of
films that you can really think about
doing unless you're willing to really as
that wonderful young man said borrow the
credit cards and do it yourself I've
often thought that if you took the ten
greatest filmmakers of the world whoever
they might be from any country and say
the 10 greatest artists painters plastic
artists and you took those 10 films and
took the work artwork of those painters
but the 10 films would more or less sort
of be the same I think you don't lock
the dard one said if you cut the titles
off movies that they're really pretty
much look the same whereas the 10
canings
each one would be a totally different
view of things of life of the world and
obviously the reason that the these
wonderful 10 filmmakers films are are
very very would be very very much the
same is because the system that that
they have to work in the system that
they have to find their distribution and
financing wants it to be that way but
that cinema itself is of unlimited
variety and my feeling is that that it's
becomes the role of the of the new
filmmaker of film artists to try to
educate the heads of companies that make
the decisions that there can be many
kinds of films if they don't know what
is gonna be the successful kind of film
the best thing is that what one responds
to what the artist himself is thinking
about and that their there needs to be a
process that one
always has to educate not only the
people making the decisions of what
films you can make with audiences
themselves if they don't have the
opportunity to have this kind of variety
that would seem to me that the types of
films that can be made will just become
more and more I think now is like about
four movies you can get made four types
of movies you can get made I would like
to see that change I think that among us
one thing I've noticed is that there is
this fraternity I talked about this due
to common love of the films that then
maybe maybe want to even talk about a
code of honor that could exist between
people who make films I would throw out
I scribble down what I would think is a
code of honor things like one absolutely
never ever make negative comments about
a film that you've been invited to see
that isn't finished we surprised how
often I see that rule violated once I
was invited to a film when I was a young
UCLA film student film by Terry and
Dennis Sanders who were great idols of
mine and I was invited to see this this
film and it was just being edited and
later they said what did you think and I
said well you know I didn't like it very
much and one older student said to me
never never make negative comments about
a film that you've seen that you were
invited to that hasn't been finished so
I would like to share that one with you
going along with that is you know like
the wine make eating never it's hard to
do but never be happy because another
filmmaker has failed or has been
perceived to be failed that that loss is
also your loss and as you begin to think
that way you really make you become
lifted just by sharing that person's
faith another part of my code of honor
might be loved actors especially when
and no matter what their foibles and
insecurities though they might be
maddening that that basic love of your
actors is a very important part of my
code of honor another note I would make
is something I got from my father which
is steal from the best
steal from the best and think of
yourselves as part of a tradition that
really goes back thousands of years and
that you will hand over to others never
cooperate with publishers or authors
that would do a happy a hatchet jog on a
job on a colleague or a filmmaker
another rule of the code of honor never
disclose what your film cost or a bet in
the making of filmmaking into sports
with emphasis on films cost or what
their grosses are in in in our kind of
film that we want to do there aren't
winners and losers and I said there
there may be only winners another little
thing on my code of honor is always try
to send telegrams and greetings to
friends and colleagues on their openings
and on their on their first day of
photography that's a wonderful tradition
that I would put on my little list I
find it hard to talk about the movie
business and about creativity in general
without finding myself really thinking
and talking about America at this time
in its history as we are the glass of
water I always thought a keynote address
was at the beginning
a post note address here I guess I guess
what I feel what I want to express is I
think of United States of America as
this this nation that has this
extraordinary economy the world's
biggest economy no matter what what you
read about it has these extraordinary
natural resources and on every level of
what an industrial nations would have
and most important it has this this
natural tradition about creativity this
comes both from the early idea of
American ingenuity having to make do
with what you have a Connecticut Yankee
in King Arthur's Court but also from all
the different ethnic peoples who came
here and became part of America and
brought their artistry and this is the
process of course that's that's still
that's still happening as so many new
peoples are arriving here so we have the
tradition of creativity and the the this
tradition is part of America well I
believe in these modern times that human
Calend is the petroleum of the 21st
century it's no longer going to be about
industrial matters of producing steel it
is talent that is the most viable and
the most important you know thing that
will fuel this new era of the future
always in history they look for that one
thing it was it was bronze it was brass
it was it was oil but now it's talent
and that's why I think a lot of you know
when you talk to young people and in the
past when they would always make the
point of well if you love the Arts or
you want to be a writer or being film or
music well that's not really a viable
profession but in this new age that is
absolutely no longer true that that
talent and creativity is the most
important ingredient you can even see in
those fields that America is doing well
and competing well with their all fields
that that depends strongly on human
talent our so-called entertainment
industry and music industries and the
software industry
it very clear that talent is not what it
was when we were kids in the 50 when
they thought of the arts as something
that was an accessory to life now
creativity is pivotal to this nation's
and to this world prosperity and
well-being talent is really valuable and
therefore all of you here who have
chosen to be in this field are not only
a possibility to make fortunes of
yourself or have your mother see you on
television or whatever it is but also to
really contribute to the future of the
world in a much more direct way than
maybe would have been possible in the
past makes me think of really of how we
can cultivate that extraordinary part of
our country the youth in and in in youth
is an area the young people of the
country they their laws they can't go
here they can't go there they can't
drink they can't skateboard on the
sidewalk they're not welcome for
insurance purposes to this place or that
place and yet they they need to be
brought into this idea that creativity
is ultimately the most important human
activity it reflects what we see in the
creation I mean we see the abundance and
the extraordinary variety and creativity
in the in the world we're born into and
here we are we have the opportunity to
to emulate that divine creative force
whatever it is and it's so clearly in
these times that not only does that
become something so desirable but also
even economically a important
underpinning of really where our nation
in the world is going to
also you know one of my feelings about
that is that it's not as though just a
few people are going to be the creative
ones or to make the films of course all
people are creative all you see that
with children how how tremendously
creative little children are until
finally through the process of their
education and being reprimanded for
doing this or that that that as we grow
into adult adult life it's only those
few the ones with the happy unhappy
childhoods that seem to read to retain
that but but in fact it's a gift that
everyone has and so when I talk about
artists and creative people being more
part of our society it doesn't mean for
just a few it means that that will be a
tenor that will be a style of our people
in general I I think sometimes I wonder
you know you can always tell about power
who has the power by looking back in
history and and and seeing who's
employing the artists in the past of
course we know that the despots the
monarchs the kings you can tell from the
great temples that have been left they
employ the artists and then of course
the Catholic Church employed the artist
for years and years and then in more
modern history I guess the various
socialist States employed the artists
well today it seems that the the
mercantile system employs the artists
that the greatest artists of our time
are involved in in basically selling and
selling products you see you see this
this misappropriation of the most
precious element of our of our times
which is creativity being used
spectacularly to sell products on
television or to sell politics or even
to sell news I mean I wonder as I look
and so what will happen if news just
continues to be titillating it does it
mean that the news that is not
titillating or has not been presented as
titillating no longer will be news so
that my notion is that maybe we're at an
age
when are the artists shouldn't really be
employed by another group that artists
should should stand as a part of society
rather than as an employee of a certain
power aspect of society and that that
maybe we're in an era where artists will
be involved in every walk of life of our
our country in other words what if what
if they weren't employees but part what
if wherever scientists grouped together
to find the cure there were some artists
working with them to help open their
eyes or wherever politicians were
laboring to devise some social system
and productive ways and to work in the
future
the artists were working with them you
know whenever budgets were falling apart
in education systems were faltering and
you know human misery and squalor
proliferating maybe there should be some
artists shoulder to shoulder with the
other leaders of the society giving them
new perspectives because I really
believe that artists are the radar of
society where artists are that look
maybe a little ahead that says look what
I see and how can we use what I see to
deal with some of these questions to
give ourselves more of a long-term
approach to the problems that we we are
facing and and as I said I think all
people are in part artists and can be
artists all it takes to really be an
artist I think I thought of that this
morning well what does it really take I
think only maybe maybe it takes real
true honesty because you can only be an
artist I think if you are really sincere
and you're expressing what you think and
what you feel and then perhaps it's a
love of beauty and a love of innovation
and that those are the real criteria to
be an artist not whether or not you're
rated high or low my father used to
always when he was in a crummy mood
especially when I was making him change
some music he would always say to me oh
well he said I guess I'm just a shit
composer he would say I don't know
you're not a shit composer you're a good
composer no no he says you wanted to
change it and I'm just a shit composer
so well that are you the greatest
composer in the world or the greatest
composer for you no you're not
you know you're not as great as Brahms
you're not as great as Mozart so what's
the difference you're just a composer
that's good enough and you know so many
of us wonder about how our rating is
whether I am as good as this one
you're never gonna be the greatest film
director in history no matter who you
are you're not even gonna be probably
it's not even important in fact the best
way to not even enter their hallowed
group is to worry about it so so so I'm
trying to I'm trying to learn thank you
try to learn myself from what I told my
father and a lot of time as you see from
this little clip I can get pretty
depressed and my experience is that of
the the finest artist whom I have
admired more than anyone deep down in
them there is also that terror and that
insecurity that that comes that comes
part of the sincerity because if you
weren't sincerely trying to reach for
something just out of your grasp
then you wouldn't then you wouldn't you
wouldn't be an artist and I I guess I
see this notion of our society changing
so rapidly I do believe that six or
seven years from now as we look back in
the later 90s we look back four or five
six years that the world will be in will
be as and politically speaking as
different probably as it seems now to
the former people in the former Soviet
Union as they look back only a few years
ago my god what happened where is there
was that a cosmonaut who went up and
just in the time he was up he looked the
whole world change and what's gonna
happen in America to politics is going
to change as dramatically I believe in
the next five six years you already can
see the covers of Time magazine if there
is a Time magazine with the new parties
the new politics it's clear that the
world that we are going to participate
in in six seven years is going to be
quite different and although you're not
allowed to think of utopia they say that
utopia actually in Greek means nowhere
in Greek that there is it's sort of like
those numbers that Max Planck invents
that door that limits the speed of light
that there can't be utopia but
can have something a lot closer to
utopia than what we have now and we can
have it in four or five years because a
creativity and and film as Oliver's film
demonstrates it's a very very very very
powerful much more powerful tool than
than many people would wish it to be and
and that is uh so I I'm gonna try to
make this short I wrote a lot of chaotic
thoughts down here I guess I guess I do
see a new I do see a wonderful world
ahead of us that we can participate in
and I once heard something otto's Huxley
told me which was a kind of rallying
call for in something I read about his
about about utopia and it was the three
words were intelligence creativity and
friendliness and in that note I thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Francis bad news is the
keynote address that you've just heard
is at the beginning of the show the good
news is I'm making a dumb joke
go home thank you very much thank you
all for everything